investigators in Minnesota are trying to
figure out why a woman was shot and
killed by police after apparently
calling 911 to report an assault 40 year
old Justine de Mond was killed Saturday
night
the Australian native taught meditation
and spirituality and was reportedly
engaged the deadly encounter took place
in a Minneapolis neighborhood when two
officers responded to the 911 call their
body cameras were not on and patrol car
cameras did not record what happened
Michelle Miller is there with the
growing question surrounding the
shooting Michelle good morning good
morning according to the Minneapolis
Police Department all of their patrol
officers are equipped with body cameras
the Minneapolis community along with the
mayor want to know why they weren't on
during Saturday's deadly shooting
this woman was a beautiful life she was
a healer
she was loved she should be alive at a
vigil Sunday night friends and neighbors
described esteemed amond as a spiritual
leader who gave back to the community
peace flowed through her she was a
lovely lovely person if you're gonna
change a belief systems it takes a lot
you know demand was a yoga teacher who
was reportedly engaged to be married
next month I have a lot of questions
about why the body cameras weren't on
Minneapolis mayor Betsy Hodges could not
explain why police body cameras were not
rolling when a police officer opened
fire on demand
outside her home demand apparently
called 911
a Salt Saturday night the Bureau of
Criminal Apprehension says two officers
responded and at one point an officer
fired their weapon fatally striking a
woman he heard a sound in the alley so
then she called the police a man
appearing to be the son of demands
fiance posted an emotional video on
Facebook if anybody can help just call
the police and demand answers the
Minneapolis Police Department added
about six hundred body cameras for its
officers last summer that requirement
came around the same time black motorist
volando Castille was killed by an
officer in another Twin Cities area
Police Department both police officers
are now on administrative leave state
investigators say when the investigation
into this shooting is over they will
turn over the findings to the county
attorney's office for review Charlie
thanks Michelle